good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday
everybody's out of the world
happy Friday everyone congratulations
you did it you made it to the end of the
week nobody else but you congratulations
you earned this I'm looking forward to
the Bruno I don't know about you
I'm looking forward to the Bruno
as well
how's your Friday going so far it's
going well I had a nightmare that um we
did the podcast and I forgot to press
record
which nightmarish so let's all just
check that we are yes
I'm good I'm good yeah we always have
our backup recording running right it
would be you know for a rainy day and it
would be very shitty but you would have
something
but I like to imagine that like if I
didn't have that dream something like
might go wrong today you know what I
mean like I was warned you're preparing
us yeah
okay well thank you for the preparation
tell me
um you take your job too seriously
without telling me you take your job too
seriously I just dream that's the thing
about being a mogul like everyone thinks
it's So Glamorous but like you are kept
up at night worrying about your Empire
so [ __ ] true [ __ ] Sheriff Empire
no it's an Empire
just because it belongs to a woman
doesn't make enough vampire
[Laughter]
Imperial from Dynasty that plot line was
a low point in the show that plot volume
was a low point in my life
wow
um well it's Friday which is just like
an absolute Delight to be able to say
that I caught up on Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills I'm still one episode
behind but my God what an infuriating
[ __ ] show I'm actually glad I haven't
been watching it week to week because I
don't think my mental health could
possibly stand it wow that's such a
clinky dink because I caught an episode
of Southern Charm last night it was an
episode from about five weeks ago that
um you know it was the first of many
that I've missed but I turned my TV on
I'm reintroducing myself to television
and I missed the game it wasn't a
particularly good episode yet I enjoyed
yeah I mean real watching Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills is never
going to be like a bad experience
because it's just glamorous beautiful
rich women which is really wonderful but
um the episode that I watched which was
I think the second to last episode so I
still have one to catch up on you know
Rina is launching a rose
oh I didn't know Renault Rose and you
know what I'm getting like a feeling
kind of how I felt last season about
jury just like not being able to keep up
with this group of women
um I'm feeling that way about Lisa Rinna
it's just like
it's very low brow everything she kind
of does like rid of beauty and Rina Rose
and it's not like elevated yeah it's
like the sort of stuff they do on OC OC
and so she had this wine tasting and it
was like
she was like everyone has kobit so Harry
and I had to set it up ourselves so it's
like oh really like janky
um and she acted like such an animal and
it was so out of character for her
because she literally went to lunch with
Sutton and like they buried the hatchet
completely over still the Elton John
thing
and we haven't spoken about the Elton
John thing in weeks and then she gets to
her house and she literally tells Sutton
to get the [ __ ] out of her house she was
trying so hard to ensure that her Rena
Rose event makes it to air because the
women have events all the time some of
them don't make it because nothing
happens or it's just like not
consequential to the storyline she made
damn sure that her Rose line was gonna
get on air it was so obvious and and
like then in the previews for next week
she like backtracks obviously like it
and then she like she has like a
breakdown she's like I'm not doing well
like it's all very in my opinion
calculated that's so interesting and
definitely right on the money because
Jackie I've and it's never seen her even
strategy even when she was in her crazy
villain era like back in the day she
never acted like she just acted it was
[ __ ] crazy and she was saying that
she was drunk like she doesn't really do
that it was so weird yeah no there's
typically a rhyme or a reason desperate
times call for desperate measures and I
think Rena Rose is you know gonna do the
most okay and have how did the launch go
for her well no one was able to come
because Omicron moronicron I forgot what
it's called it's running rampant through
the group so at first garcelle has it
and uh then another wave comes and
Crystal gets it so half of the women
weren't even there that's so crazy
because last season they got covered
also yeah and so I guess this is January
right after the holidays when Omicron
that's when I had it yeah so it's like
half the women haven't been at half of
the [ __ ] damn okay sounds like I'm
missing nothing I'm feeling really good
about that you're missing nothing
um I still have one more episode so
everything I've just said is without the
context of the most recent episode so
please keep that in mind if you disagree
with my takes okay cool and I will keep
watching Southern Charm and eventually
be caught up and be able to share my
thoughts speaking of Southern Charm did
you know that Shep and Taylor have
broken up I did know that and then um
Olivia did an interview this week where
she said that she thought the breakup's
not permanent but they have to break up
if there's we're going like either they
have to break up because she wants
things that he doesn't want and if she
has any shot in Hell of getting him to
want those things too because he wants
her badly enough she has to put her foot
down so this is part of the natural
process for the two yeah for sure I
wasn't like surprised by their breakup
and I did see people like guessing
whether they had broken up based on
social media posts but I didn't see like
an official announcement of a breakup
that's why I was surprised
but she was on Watch What Happens Live
this week and Andy asked um her if
there's anyone in the Bravo universe
that he can set her up with now that
she's single and she said Tom Schwartz
who's also single
is that crazy obsessed I'm obsessed what
a great answer a really good answer and
I don't know her that well yet but from
what I know of her I think they would be
really compatible no I know oh my God
I'm obsessed and he asked Naomi too and
she was like no
I love that for her too she said she's
dating like someone oh great I
absolutely love that yeah so um I'm
working my way back to getting caught up
Southern Charm is not a priority for me
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills comes
first and so does only murders in the
[ __ ] building season two I love
that show so much I don't know why I
can't get my ass to start the second
season I also did not want to watch
until there was like enough episodes for
me to binge at a time because I don't do
week to week when it comes to scripted
shows I just refuse to be forced to
change my habits and now there's like a
good amount of episodes I think it might
have even been over yeah I need to watch
I need to watch too Zach has been
watching in the living room so it's just
like run through maybe we'll start
together next week and we could recap it
together oh yeah that reminds me um I
know you have a child but like I call
you and you don't answer so I have to
tell you things on the podcast if I want
to just let you know information about
my life when did you try and call me
that I didn't answer I always try and
call you back
yesterday like early afternoon interest
hunt I don't recall I literally texted
you and I also wrote down the things I
had to tell you in the text message so
that I didn't forget I don't
need [ __ ] about let me go look at my
phone whatever the other thing I wanted
to tell you is I'm obviously coming to
stay with you next week
um but for like my schedule and then the
flights I have to come on Monday instead
of Sunday okay there's nothing in my
text messages about this
Nary a thing nothing
um
we're ready
all you were asking before me for was
send me a video to make a tick tock yeah
she's not a Christian
um here call me for two things and then
in parenthesis I wrote the two things at
103 PM [ __ ] Claudia Claudia I do not
have these text messages I promise you
it goes from talking about
um I'll send you a screenshot right now
it goes from Tony okay send me a
screenshot because it goes from talking
about like the posting of the episode in
Ethernet and stuff like that and then
you send me an ethernet cord you send me
a funny comment
not yet I had Claudia I do not have
these texts email okay I'm gonna send
you what I have hold on this is so crazy
they're trying to keep us apart she
deleted them Claudia
Claudia
whatever well now is the opportunity
um to tell you all the things I've been
wanting to tell you since you didn't
call me back yesterday the first is that
um I'm staying with you obviously next
week
um but my flight is on Monday so
Monday's episode I won't be with you I
just wanted to tell the toasters that
end you that Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday next week Jackson cloud in
Florida Monday
regular this or maybe podcast only
because my flight's in the morning so
we'll have to decide okay or maybe we
could film Sunday night we'll just have
to figure that okay
um so that was like a housekeeping
update and also literally just letting
you know like I'm not arriving to your
house until Monday great can't wait to
see you whenever I do but we should
watch only murders together and then we
can recap it next week oh my God it's so
cute and cozy we could cuddle in my bed
you think bed and Sack would be fun
sleeping together yeah so me you
enrolled now that you have a king bed in
my room
um me you enrolled could totally fit oh
for sure he would love that he'd love
sleeping in bed that's his favorite I
also saw somebody suggest a good patreon
idea because when we're together we
should film some patreon content
um one you need to make like a vlog
trying different homemade baby food
recipes okay and then in the next Vlog I
need to try them
oh that's so funny also someone
suggested that we do a vlog of us
reacting to Old toast Clips since there
are so many going around the internet we
could just like pull up that talk and
yeah we could we could because it's just
hard to organize that logistically like
to watch on the screen and then for us
to watch yeah yeah to all watch together
so I liked that idea but it's just gonna
be like me being sad about like my old
face my old physique mild hair we've all
been there you know so of course oh my
God the craziest thing happened to me
last night
so Ben's best friend was his birthday
party last night and like I was so RDH
that I couldn't go but like I had to be
like a good comedian and I had to stay
back and study and I also like I
couldn't even drink because I can't
drink before a show so I have a show
tonight for those who don't know
um so I'm laying in bed I've been like
re-watching my MSG show writing down new
jokes coming up with new stuff like so
much time has passed like some jokes
don't feel relevant anymore you know
interesting yeah like the squid games
like that's like so old you know yeah
yeah I don't remember that joke though
so it can go so it obviously wasn't
memorable no but I didn't watch squid
games so it wouldn't have stuck with me
so it's 11 o'clock and my doorbell rings
which is really uncommon and I'm like
who is it and the person says Jonathan
now I know Jonathan from my building but
I was a little suspicious I'm like wait
who is it
he was like it's Jonathan I'm like oh it
is Jonathan okay and I opened the door
and Jonathan is standing outside my door
with 15 boxes of pizza
now I was immediately like shook because
I thought someone was playing a prank on
me when I was in high school this is
actually a crazy story when I was in
high school I was a senior there was a
prank being done onto our school
and it was like a mystery who the prank
every couple of days like a huge order
of pizza would arrive at the front desk
like reception of the school
um and nobody would know where it came
from it wasn't paid for it was like a
delivery and it was always from
different restaurants and the
administration of the school like did
everything in their power to try and
figure out like who was placing these
orders and it was particularly nefarious
one because like you're like scamming a
local business out of money because they
were always ordering from non-kosher
pizza restaurants and literally you're
we're not allowed to bring non-kosher
food into our school it was a kosher
building
um so it was like this huge predicament
and it was this huge mystery who did it
and literally we never found out who did
it maybe now you putting this I don't
really remember this maybe I graduated
but maybe now that you're sharing you
had graduated I was a senior it was like
boys in my grade oh okay maybe someone
will come forward now
perhaps it was so like I remember
thinking it was not funny and like not
cool of anyone like wasting the
restaurant's time and resources the
different person's time and resources so
taking non-kosher food into a sacred
building it's a waste of food I do
believe that's what the school ended up
doing like paying for it and then
bringing it to like a shelter or
something
um and that's what I thought was
happening to me last night because I
just had like a media flashback
flashback of like an unexpected delivery
of a huge order of pizza it turns out
that Ben Ben's party trick is
running to the bathroom ordering pizza
on his phone for the party and then like
10 minutes later it arrives and
everyone's like oh my God who ordered
pizza and when they find out it's been
it's like everyone's like bad bad like
that's his favorite thing it's actually
a really good party trick I'm never not
grateful for you so when it arrives like
because I'm like really bad and you're
gonna do it again and then he does it
I'm like you know what still slap it's
every time
so I was like after I thought it was a
prank I knew immediately that Ben did
his party trick and he chose the wrong
address he just had it sent to like his
seamless go-to address which is mine and
I would have like couriered it over or
like put it in an Uber and sent it down
but Ben was so far like we were on
opposite sides of the city like it
wouldn't have made any sense so I ended
up just like there's a lot of guys who
work in my building so it's in the break
room and this morning they were like oh
my pizza for breakfast pizza for lunch
pizza for dinner
um it was so much pizza I'm like you
guys are gonna be eating pizza till the
end of the year yeah that's so it was so
I did obviously grab I was gonna ask and
was it good pizza it was Joe's Pizza
which is arguably the best pizza in the
city wow your cup run it's over so yoga
is like Jonathan no I was like Jonathan
take it down but just like open the top
box and let me get a slice first
damn how's Theo doing
thank you thank you so much for asking
he's doing well he's doing better he's
taking to his antibiotics but
um he's also on an anti-itching pill and
it's not working as fast as I need it to
work because every time I take the cone
off he immediately goes to lick his foot
so I have to put the cone back on I want
to help him but I can't
oh Theo we're thinking of you thoughts
and prayers tags thoughts and prayers
let's just all say a silent prayer for
theaters Theo's itchy foot
I hope we're able to sync up Bryce is
great he's right here you can't see him
but the YouTubers can and he's just
being an angel he's so excited but a
little nervous because Magnolia is
coming to stay with us and theosui has
like a full house full of like his best
friend arch nemesis and his lady love
and he's taking his job as host really
seriously
not me totally forgetting that Margo's
also staying at your house like I don't
know why I thought it was just gonna be
like me you enrolled and Zach well for a
few days it will be and then the
snatcher's coming oh that's why right
because she has to work so she can't she
come the whole time yeah um but it's
gonna be a full house full of pups and
I'm literally so [ __ ] excited
about three pups in one house that's
exciting it's the dream for these boys
did you get your toad situation like
fully no and it won't be fully fleshed
out so it will be an indoor weekend for
the boys I'm sorry I did the best I
could that's okay that's okay I know
these things take time yeah next time
it'll be safe and sound out there
um so now we're what two weeks maybe
three weeks you living in Florida how's
the homeowner life
it's never ending yeah it's never ending
there are so many different facets like
the inside the outside the furniture
the the perimeter like the guts like the
gutters the intestines of the house it's
[ __ ] crazy
um I'm so excited for when we're settled
and like all of this is it's done done
um and it makes you just like want to
rip the band they'd often do everything
but then there's so much going on it's
like whoa let's do one thing at a time
and then it's like how come nothing's
getting done no
also like I do feel like a good rule of
thumb is like not to do everything at
once like financially it doesn't make
the most sense mental health-wise it
does not make the most sense to like
keep having construction like not
everything has to be done it just has to
be livable yeah no and it's definitely
livable and I think like
by next week like it will be a lot more
quiet around here I'm really excited
about that and then I do need to focus
on like Furniture I've gotten so much
stuff already like I've also came with
all my New York stuff but I have more
space than I've ever had in my life
um so I just keep needing things you
know like I need a duvet insert like
there's just always something that I
need I need bath mats for my bathroom
like and these are just small things I
also need
a million other things so it's just
never ending but it's it's a fun project
but it's overwhelming you know for sure
homes are literally money pits like they
just require so much upkeep they really
really do especially when you just move
in and there's just so many like little
things that I want to do and now you
know I'm obsessed with wallpaper I'm
addicted you know I need rugs I just I'm
actually getting some Jill's iron rigs
I'm so excited I'm telling you Jill's
Aaron rugs are are legit and I'm not
just saying that like I have really some
great ones coming indoor and outdoor I'm
actually getting the rug that we have in
our studio because it's a great rug
hopefully I can keep it cleaner than we
did over there
um but also some like patio rugs I'm
really this rug you're getting yeah for
for your room
are you sure it sounded Jill's Aaron
I thought you said it was
it used to be but we like took a dump on
that one okay so whichever like the
Shaggy
salt colored rug okay good because I was
like this rug is like disgusting even
before it was made gross by us it's like
the ugliest rag I'm like get that [ __ ]
out of my room but okay it's the classic
cream Jill's ironwork I'm getting for
your bedroom oh good good her rugs are
good yeah so there's just a million
things whilst also you know being a
working mom a mogul pumping nursing
slowing down but still doing all that
it's just a million things I still need
to like and then and then it's like
phase two of like okay once I'm a little
more settled I can take my driving
classes right but it's just never are
you gonna do like group driving class or
like a solo more like a private driving
driver's head you are but like I could
see literally the sitcom that is you and
the people in your drive adult driving
class I would only do it if they let me
Vlog them uh hundred percent it would be
an actual sitcom I should bring a camera
crew with me I feel like everyone has
like a a hilarious or traumatic driver's
ed story like mine was after school and
it was we used to always get like food
after school we'd always go to Serafina
and get pasta and then we'd get in the
car meet my friend Rachel my friend
Alicia and this boy Reuben from our
class and we were such terrible drivers
and we were like bellies full of pennile
vodka in the back seat
stop start stop start it was a miserable
experience I actually found out recently
that my driver's ed teacher who like was
an icon living legend passed away that's
so sad so sad yeah no I'm not looking I
hope I do private lessons
um I would do group if that's you know
the most expeditious way to get it done
but I feel like I'm always in situations
like this where it's like I'm in a room
full of strangers like doing weird
things you know no of course and by the
way the worst part like group is sounds
funny in theory but then your ass has to
sit and watch other morons Drive oh
goodness gracious no thank you no thank
you and then we'll like be playing
icebreakers in the car like I
so my name is Jackie I'm originally from
New York and my favorite pizza topping
is cheese
yeah
the worst Icebreaker by the way like
what's your favorite pizza topping never
played that I've never gotten oh it's a
closet I've never sung so low it's a
classic
um okay it's Friday we have a great show
I'm ready to dive in
um off the deep end you know
I'm ready to dive in as well to the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
osia dewy Summer Skin isn't just for
your face with the right products you
can get a full body glow OCS skin care
and body care products help get your
skin ready for every summer look so you
can experience radiant Summer Skin with
OCS on Daria algae algae body oil so it
keeps her skin soft and glowing with the
andaria all day which has acai pulp
babasu seed oil which is a rich and
never greasy luxurious Body Oil that's
fragrant with sunny Citrus and notes of
sweet passion fruit like the glazed
donut look is totally in and it's not
just for your face whether you're
showing leg at a wedding or a cocktail
party or you're out I don't know sexy
collarbone moment make sure your skin is
hydrated and refreshed and dewy and
glowy with OCS andaria algae body oil
and their total body glow Trio kit so
the kit includes the body oil a
moisturizing body scrub and a
plant-based body brush it sweeps away
dense dead skin cells then hydrates for
incredibly soft glowy skin All Summer
Long find introduce skin care and Body
Care favorites at ocmalibu.com get a
special discount just for our listeners
10 off your first order site-wide with
promo code toast you'll get free samples
with every order and orders over 50 get
free shipping you're going to wanna
get it all so go to o s e a malibu.com
promo code toast osea is spelled o-s-e-a
malibu.com that promo code is toast for
10 off your first order and don't forget
you get free samples with every order
over fifty dollars you also get free
shipping great thank you it's pleasure
doing business with you happy Friday
so you can sing your song
who's pleasure oh that's also on
toastunes I feel like every time we
mention toes Tunes we don't think of
that song yeah we need to do a list and
then we need to book studio time
100 yeah I'm starting to think about
like when my first trip back to New York
will be like in all the things that I
need to do while I'm there and I think
that's when we should record toast Tunes
okay I mean the thing is it's not even
about booking studio time and I just
keep saying this in the hopes that the
right person with the right set of
skills will reach out like if you are a
music producer like you produce original
tracks you don't have to be hella
experienced like we need someone to
actually before we get in the studio
like we need to have someone create the
song like the background to what we're
singing okay
someone do it
please someone reach out like we need
your help we do our first story is a
very sad turn of events um Anne Heche is
quote not expected to survive her car
crash the actresses reptile page six
Thursday night that she suffered a
severe anoxic brain injury due to the
accident and remains in a coma at the
Grossman Burn Center at West Hills
Hospital and Medical Center in
California quote Isla it has long been
her choice to donate her organs and
she's being kept on life support to
determine if the if any are viable her
rep think her fans for their kind wishes
and prayers as well as the dedicated
staff and the wonderful nurses who have
cared for her since the wreck
you know what like I know we've been
talking about this all week but I don't
know why this really surprised me I
wasn't
expecting like I felt like the details
we knew up until this point were like it
was serious but like it wasn't fatal
yeah um and when I saw I got a People
notification it was like not expected to
survive I was like oh I don't know why I
was like completely shocked no I was
completely shocked too because that's
not uh how it seemed earlier this week
and you know maybe they just for taking
their time to share the news as they saw
fit and also as we like discussed the
other day she was in a coma it was
unclear if it was radically induced but
it was not and so this is just a really
really sad
tragic turn of events right like to know
what's coming but um if you wanted to
look at the positive you know as an
organ donor hopefully she'll be able to
make a positive impact definitely
wishing her family really truly the best
yeah
okay our next story some drama Jay
colors responding to Kristin Cavallari
calling their marriage toxic so Jay
Cutler went on Sofia with an f and I
mean which was just interesting timing
seeing as how Kristen Cavallari was just
on call her daddy I'm in the middle of
this Sofia with an F episode I'm
obsessed
that would be a really good couple I
feel like I think Sophia is single right
I think she posted that it's never
really clear clear right yeah I mean I
think that's extremely intentional since
like the last time the public knew about
her relationship they tore to shreds
right but also I think she's also like
just like that Carefree girly like I
feel like when I talk to her I'm like
are you single and she answers me I
never know what she says you know yeah
yeah I feel that so it's it's possible
is what you're saying yeah and Jay color
is hot yeah no and the report was so
funny and cute I didn't watch I just saw
Clips on Instagram but like what I was
focusing on and I think what a lot of
people were focusing on was like the
timing of her inviting words of course
it was like so funny because they call
her daddy Saga is a saga that never ends
at least in my mind like I
feel like there's so much tension and
it's so unresolved yeah of course I mean
I would love to know how this came about
like Kristen took her story to call her
daddy and like share it and talked about
Jay a little bit and like called the
relationship really toxic and there was
tons of red flags and the reason why
they broke up their engagement before
they even got married was the same
reason they eventually got divorced like
you know people don't change
um right and I just would love to know
if Jay reached out to Sophia or Sophia
reached out to Jay whose idea was this
it's [ __ ] hysterical right because
also so
um Kristen it's not like she was on like
a press tour like Arduino who was on
call her daddy recently is promoting her
book well I think Christian's also
promoting her podcast her right right I
guess yeah
but what I found interesting and the
only clip I saw from the Sophia
interview which was just a really good
point is like Sophia you know heard what
Kristen Cavallari had said about Jay
Cutler and every time she you know kind
of dragged him or called him toxic she
would say right before that you know
he's the father of my children so I'm
not gonna go there but he's toxic but
here I go yeah right right which I
thought was really funny
um I don't have a particular stake in
the uh Jay Cutler Kristen Cavallari
divorce like I don't care really
um I'm just interested in the podcast
drama of it all and you know I think a
press moment for podcasts is a win for
podcasts everywhere yeah and this is
just like another layer of the Alex
Sofia thing which we devoured when it
came out and honestly I'm like still
obsessed with yes I also am obsessed
with Jay and Kristen and he says like
they're
dissolution of their relationship
actually makes me sad
they were on very Cavalry together and
he talks about his experience filming
the show and how he really didn't want
to be there but Kristen like was a
football wife for so many years that now
it was like her time to shine and so he
wasn't gonna say like no I can't but you
could sense that he doesn't want to be
there but honestly like it came off so
funny I thought that people really liked
him on the show because he was so
unbothered but and you could see then
like we always talk about this I just
feel like sometimes when you see a
relationship on a show and like it looks
like there's something wrong it's like
well the fact that they're showing that
to us kind of shows that it's healthy
you know that's true and that's sort of
how I felt about them like they were
very like honest about their Dynamic
um but clearly it was just a little too
real and I mean yeah and I was like a
big fan of them when they were together
I thought they were like a really
well-matched couple but now with the
dissolution and like the divorce I find
myself caring less because like I just
don't care yeah but they do have three
kids and they'll always actually be in
each other's eyes but it's also funny
like the stuff with Madison Lacroix lest
we not forget and
because Kristen was like hanging out
with Austin so Jay the world is so small
but then like Madison
she posted those text messages and that
was not the move
because Chris the world is tiniest
posted together like United
right which was like kind of [ __ ] up
to Madison when he was like playing with
Madison you know yeah no but it's just
it never ends no it never ends and
everyone is connected I keep forgetting
like
well I totally forgot about the Madison
Lacroix thing first of all that was so
long ago and you just forget how like
literally everyone who's famous is
connected in some weird way yes and so I
don't know what Jay's relationship
status is currently maybe if I keep
listening I'll find out I feel like he's
always dating and being spotted with
people but I would love to see him
spotted with Sophia with an F no no I
need them today like I I'm putting like
the level of pressure I put on Paige and
Craig
on Jay I'm officially transferring I
feel like they're good page and credit
like I feel good they're secure they're
stable I'm officially releasing them of
my handcuffs and those handcuffs are on
Jay and Sophia now they don't need like
that positive energy and encouragement
and like karmic
yeah positivity but those two do yeah
yeah and I just feel like it's like a
perfect match one because like he's so
hot and Rich she is like so hot and
funny and like she does come from
Barstool Sports and like Barstool Sports
like turned on her but if she ends up
with Jay Cutler like I think he's like a
really good football player well yeah
former football player then it's like
she comes out on top of like the whole
Sports thing you know that's very true
I just love it but as stated in the
podcast she really doesn't care about
sports which also makes it better and
she talks about like the I think the
episode's called like Cloud chasing
because she's like so many girls who
listen to the podcast like want to land
an athlete what do they do how but she
was saying that she wouldn't date an
athlete
maybe she was just like playing card
together no it was a really good
strategy I think that
there's something there I would not be
surprised like if they were spotted out
I need a page six moment like like a
dinner at Katsuya something I don't know
yeah and she was in Nashville so I don't
know if she like went explicitly for
this interview and who reached out to
who or she was staying at his house or
she was staying at his house also I
believe she was on his podcast
maybe okay like maybe this is how it
happened she was staying at his house
and the Christian the Christian
Cavallari interview came out I think
they were dating first yeah and he was
like really upset he was like babe I
hate that she's calling me toxic like I
feel so helpless what do I do and she
was like babe like and they're in bed
the whole time naked by the way and
she's like babe like you could come on
my podcast no one obviously will know
we're dating it will just be like a
typical interview and then the internet
will ship us but we're already shipped
and we come out on top babe what about
this take it back one step further we
thought that like Jay went on Sophia
because Kristen went on
call her daddy but but maybe they've
been dating for so long and like Kristen
knew that that's
Jay's new girl and so she was like I'll
go and call her daddy
but I see that but my only thing is
wasn't Jay responding to like some of
this stuff Kristen said odd call her
daddy
yeah also because you think it had to
happen afterwards is this like back and
forth it's all true than like Jay and
Kristen are you just still hung up on
each other
it's like not normal to be talking about
your ex like this far out yeah and it's
like every time one of them like okay
I'm with Austin so I'll be with Madison
okay they're one-upping each other yeah
yeah oh my God totally I'm with Claudia
I'm with Jackie totally
yeah that's and you guys know like I
have oh actually I forgot to update
everyone about my personal beef with
Chris and Cavalieri that I'm sure she
doesn't even know about
um I was reached out to you by a member
of her team
apologizing you know they said it was
one girl's fault and that girl doesn't
work here anymore which is just hella
convenient that it happened to be one
girl's fault and that one girl doesn't
work there anymore but they were really
nice about it I'm officially over it
even though I would love about apology
from Kristen herself I'm done I'm
overhead yeah
good I just don't like people who take
advantage of small business oh my God
they handle them they they made it right
they made it right and they reached out
and they didn't have to
yeah no it was nice it was nice I'm I'm
over it
not at all no I am I am
okay well hopefully there's something to
keep you posted about this story and
these two I never then just everyone say
a prayer
so far I have two new ship Enterprises
from today's episode okay who's the next
Taylor and and Tom Schwartz oh right
right I thought you were that was like a
segue into the next story no our next
story is another ship that's out to see
that seems to be fine even though
everybody's coming for it Pirates are
surrounding Melissa and Joe Gorga
address their devastating decision to
skip Teresa giudice's wedding so Melissa
Andro are addressing the elephant in the
room on this week's episode of Melissa
Gorga on display podcast you guys every
story is podcast news like where do
people wait share their truths if not on
podcasts okay I want to talk about this
but I wanted to say one thing you know
that Teresa also just announced a
podcast called Namaste on the same
network as Melissa's I saw that she
announced podcast didn't know it was
called Namaste and didn't put together
that they're on the same network it is a
big Network though yeah it's podcast one
it's huge it's like one of the OG
networks but um I also want to say I
have done Melissa gorgas podcast she has
a real knack for it and as far as I know
as someone who's like you know know
obsessed with like stalking and just
knowing everything about everyone her
podcast is extremely successful yeah I'm
sure it is she's great for it and I
don't think of course I'm comparing like
what Teresa's is going to be I don't
think Teresa has the capacity podcasting
is very difficult people think it's so
easy like oh I'm so funny me and my
friends we hang out like we should have
a bad cat no it's actually extremely
difficult I agree I wouldn't say that
that's you know Teresa's trip but I
would choose for her but give it a shot
go girl yeah anyways Melissa and Joe
went on Melissa's podcast to talk about
the laundry list of reasons they didn't
attend the wedding quote I will let all
my listeners know this obviously there
was something that went down at the
season 13 finale of filming the real
houses of New Jersey those exact details
I obviously cannot say today anything
that we have filmed is something that I
am not able to talk about she then
confirmed that the full entire story
leading to attention amongst the family
is not public knowledge at this time but
drips and drabs of it have surfaced she
said quote I'm not going to sit here and
say that there wasn't drama that it
wasn't crazy yes there was a little
aggression from certain people that
could have been a little scary she noted
there was plenty of Reason it'd be
strange for the pair to attend the
wedding thereafter Joe said it was so so
hard for him to not attend Teresa's
wedding especially since he's his only
she's his only close family that's still
alive he said quote to me it was
devastating it really was it was one of
the hardest days of my life it was bad
but listen let's go back to the reunion
she did this you know this was all on
her this is what she really wanted she
didn't want Melissa in the wedding she
didn't want any of my children in the
wedding she barely wanted me
well
um this is like the craziest Saga of
events and I feel really sad that the
families can't work it out yeah I agree
I'm glad that they like
took the time to explain to everyone
because I think a lot of people are like
yes we understand that Teresa's uh you
know a hard
tough cookie but it's family and it's a
wedding and why weren't you there so I
I'm glad that they shared this and I can
only imagine like really what they went
through and what the season has to hold
and has in store for us to see and I
totally respect their decision and I
imagine it's extremely difficult and
this is not something that they did like
capriciously this has been now 13 years
of all of this drama and they've they
put their foot down I get it
no and I have respect for it I made the
atrocious mistake of going on Twitter to
see what people's thoughts are I mean I
cannot believe how many toxic Teresa
stands exist it's so mind-blowing to me
that you could come to the conclusion
after watching the show that Teresa has
somehow been wronged yeah no Twitter's a
great place to go if you want to hear
like the worst takes of all time
especially as it relates to Housewives
and then sometimes I go to Twitter like
I agree with whatever I'm saying and I'm
like so I'm wrong rethink recalibrate
yeah no
recalibrate it's so and by the way I
totally support Melissa I love the
decision that she made I think she
really did her her best I know a lot of
the drama that people are like guessing
is is what happened is about Melissa
cheating on Joe and Daily Mail claims to
know the guy everyone knows the guy
um and I just hate that we don't know
him We're Not Gonna Know for so long
like what the actual issue is he was but
I do think that this sort of thing will
keep people interested till the season
premieres like it's not something we're
just going to forget and then by the
time opinions would be like we're over
it because no this is a big deal so I'm
happy for the ratings
amigio no Jersey Jersey stays winning
yeah
um before you dive into the next story
can I just tell you about next Evo
Naturals you can I've been waiting to
hear about it if you've ever wondered
whether your CBD was working that means
it probably wasn't next Evo Naturals
developed smartsorb technology
clinically proven to help your body
absorb CBD four times better than
regular CBD oil because oil just doesn't
mix with your water-based body it works
faster too when you feel stress coming
on you won't waste time wondering is it
working I'm a CBD girly I like taking
CBD in a bunch of different methods with
a bunch of different mediums and why I
like next Evo CBD is because they're all
natural products are backed by more
scientific studies than any other CBD
brand they're vegan GMO free gluten-free
THC free capsules and their gummies are
derived from 100 U.S grown hemp so if
you've been wanting to try CBD or you're
not happy with your current CBD company
try the next Evo Naturals capsules
gummies mints and topical creams that
are clinically proven to be better
absorbed by your body get 25 off your
next order of 40 or more at next evo.com
promo code toast that's 25 off
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code toast great
okay our next story is some wonderful
deserving news Keenan Thompson has been
honored with the star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame one of SNL's favorite funny
man is finally getting the recognition
he deserves comedian and actor Keenan
Thompson hit a major career Milestone
this week by being honored with the star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
the actors showed up in style for his
big moment decked out an all-navy suit
as he was joined by his two daughters
for the career-making night his former
co-star Leslie Jones hyped him up as she
eagerly recorded the Stars unveiling
making sure she got a close-up of
Keenan's shining new accomplishment and
later giving a speech in his honor in
addition Josh server his former co-star
from Nickelodeon sketch series all that
also gave a speech to honor his friend
and his star is right next to Lauren
Michaels's star oh wow I'm sad Kell
wasn't there I feel like that she should
have been that's true um and I always
find it really interesting what
celebrities have who who celebrities
choose other celebrities to like speak
at their Hollywood Walk of Fame moment
um I love that Leslie Jones was there I
watched the video of him unveiling a
star and like his daughters like
couldn't have cared less and Lizzie
Jones was like losing her mind it was so
funny and so cute and so real
um and I'm just surprised he didn't have
one already and then you know it makes
me sit back and think about Keenan
Thompson especially now watching um I
mean I'm watching I'm reading Jeanette
McCurdy's book like Keenan Thompson is
Loki a child actor
right but oh I'm sorry he was in
heavyweights he's not Loki he was like
literally 10 in that movie but find you
like a more stable
consistent guy and you know on more than
one occasion I've like had an Uber
driver who like likes to tell me about
famous people they've driven and I've
gotten like more than once someone who's
driven Keenan Thompson on Saturday to
Saturday Night Live like he's always
going back and forth from his apartment
he doesn't have a chauffeur he's an Uber
Regular Guy and
um they say he's so nice so funny so
down to earth
um and that's just like surprising
obviously for someone so famous but also
someone who's really been a star since
they were like 10. and he never went
through like a weird period no he didn't
he's now been on SNL for 20 Seasons he's
the longest running cast member and it's
just crazy to think about also in this
article I saw that he's hosting the
Emmys which I don't think I knew and I
saw this week that the Emmys are
actually going back to cable no that was
the golden one of them Golden Gloves are
done no but one of them's coming back
they were done but they're coming back
to TV I think it might be the Golden
Globes
anyways
Keenan Thompson is always getting
shafted like NBC gave him a sitcom it
was canceled oh I wonder why maybe
because I never saw a commercial for it
oh Canon Thompson is hosting the Emmys
who knew because they don't promote it
like right he's always like doing the
most and getting the least that's
genuinely how I feel it's so true
whenever someone makes hosting news
especially like for the Emmys it would
usually huge I didn't see it
he'll do a great job
he's hilarious he for so long has held
SNL together by a thread he literally
puts the whole show on his back him and
Kate McKinnon now she's gone so
um I hope he makes a lot of money
because he works extremely hard yeah and
I think it's really nice that he got the
honor of being next to Lauren yeah
because there are so many people who
would probably attribute their whole
lives to Lauren Tina Fey Jimmy Fallon
Chris Rock like so many people Adam
Sandler yeah no it's it's a great honor
and he he's so deserving a hundred
percent
and
are you ready for our fifth and final
Story the final story
what's it about jacket tell us please
Number Six Flags Six Flags is making
news the CEO is speaking to the Press
about this revamper Six Flags because
they have become quote a cheap daycare
center for teenagers
yeah no he's like not holding back but I
kind of love this for him Six Flags
revealed it has shed nearly 2 million
customers during the past year a drop
that came partly because of an
initiative to weed out Rowdy teenagers
according to the company CEO the
texas-based theme park shares tumble to
18 on Thursday after it disclosed that
its attendance at its 27 Parks was down
22 from a year ago the drop came partly
because Six Flags has been steadily
hiking ticket prices after offering too
many discounts this year quote so we
only got the Discounter or we became a
cheap daycare center for teenagers it
was a cheap daycare center for teenagers
during breaks and the summers in
response Six Flags has been hiking
prices to reduce the numbers of Rowdy
teenagers running around also in the
past the rowdiness has turned violent
with Fikes breaking out at different
theme parks during Fright Night
so now they're elevating their ticket
prices to focus on elevating the guest
experience and to learn like more
families but the ticket price still
isn't that it's 63 dollars compared to
51 last year but for reference like Sea
World a ticket is a hundred and sixteen
dollars
wow who would pay 116 dollars to Mock
and captured animals someone a lot of
someone's would so they're they're
trying to I don't know I guess like
Rebrand and just not become a place
where teens hang out and fight no let me
say something like I I understand the
liability of it because if teenagers are
like fighting and creating drama
but I do think this is like an extremely
um
risky idea because first of all sounds
like they're isolating like their
biggest demographic of customers like
kids teenagers like who kids and
teenagers are different like
for kids and Families
no I'm talking about teenagers yeah
so you're isolating and like excluding
your biggest core demographic even
though they do pose an issue like that's
still
a big group of people who are your
customers
what else are you doing to elevate
because Six Flags in a world of like the
Disneylands and all the dolly world like
all these other Harry Potter World Six
Flags is Loki are element and like kind
of janky and like they have to be doing
other things if they actually want to
compete like cleaning up the parks new
rides new this I feel like for a while
they were like top top
tier of amusement parks and now they're
like a relevant uglies gullible big face
witches well I feel like that's what
they're trying to
counter but I also think that their
biggest demographic is families and
maybe having Rowdy teenagers is keeping
families out they're like we don't want
to be in this environment with our kids
so it actually will learn in more
customers and they're losing customers
but they're raising the ticket prices so
maybe at the end of the day they'll make
the same amount of money the only thing
is like
for a teenager to like go and like get
in trouble I mean aside from fighting
and violence never condone it ever but
like Rowdy teenagers going and spending
their time at Six Flags like it's kind
of cute like and you know it's like kind
of a loser and so how much trouble could
they get in right and it's not like I
don't think they sell alcohol like okay
so that's where they're going like I
worry to think about where those teens
will go instead maybe they should go
home to their parents and find and mow
the lawn no like kids need kids need
like you know routines and instructions
and when they're left to their own
devices they're starting fights at Six
Flags yeah I don't think that they're
gonna go home though I just I hope they
don't get into some real trouble no like
does this Elevate like where they go to
next no I know like we're they're
literally just placing the teenagers
yeah and the teenagers need help and
they need places to go to have like good
fun you know instead of turning to
to bad things I will say in defense of
the teenagers at that age there aren't
like a ton of options for like fun cool
places to hang out because you're stuck
between like not being 21 and then not
wanting to hang out at like a Chuck E
cheese or a roller rink
um so like there's really not that's why
you're always like hanging out in
someone's basement but there's not a lot
of options for like 16 17 year olds who
know how to drive who have like access
they have jobs they have money like they
can go but like where do they go yeah
where did you guys hang out as 16 year
olds for me like I was always at
Serafina yeah we hung out at Pinkberry
yeah where do the kids hang out today
and where did you guys hang out I think
it depends where you're from yeah where
you live
but it's tough out there for the teens
no for sure like I sympathize with like
not having like a
a nice fun clean place to organize like
if you find somewhere to go say it's
your local bowling alley anywhere you
better act right you better treat it
with respect you better not fight you
better pick up after yourself otherwise
you're giving teens around the world a
bad name
just like these kids at Six Flags you've
ruined it for everyone yeah
congratulations you played yourself you
got it's the one you got
that was an interesting business segment
thank you so much for bringing that to
my attention I have forgotten about that
brand when I saw the headline I found it
to be interesting the CEO is just like
kicking out of the teens he's literally
like who's the villain from that movie
who like hates kids
which movie I don't know but like it's
like a come on help like that guy
oh speaking of movies we need to talk
about like the greatest debate ever
sparked yesterday was Elwood's
valedictorian it's not even a debate I
went back and watched the whole clip
she's not the valedictorian there's no
debate thank you she's not I thought you
were gonna like go toe-to-toe with me
again no they literally said please
welcome the class elected speaker L
Woods if she was valedictorian please
welcome the valedictorian L Woods she's
a [ __ ] class elected speaker
which is a huge honor I'm sure you have
to have good grades but you're not the
[ __ ] valedictorian I was wrong
there's no debate okay great but I do
want to say apparently in the musical
like in the song She's a valedictorian I
don't care that's not what we obviously
we're not referring to the musical no
and that's not the original also that's
a plot hole because if you know I L
Woods I love
forever like she is everything to me but
she's not valedictorian material that's
not why we love L like she is everything
else but you can't be L and be fabulous
and be street smart and get off social
stuff and have the highest grades at
Harvard Law School it's just not how it
works in life no that's fair she got a
179 on the LSAT like there are people
who got a perfect score
uh 179 is actually not even a score you
can literally get it's like impossible
like based on how this yes or squared
yeah 179
she's so iconic because nobody will ever
say the number 179
normally ever again because if I oh
Claudia what street are you on 179th
Claudia how much how many munchkins did
you eat from Dunkin Donuts 179.
Claudia how much do you weigh
79
um okay so that's our show I have to
head to West Hampton now because I have
a show today the greatest time are you
gonna make it uh Hampton's weekend of it
no because I would like to relax at home
for a little while and then I'm leaving
to see you
so I'll get in you know a few more
sleeps in my bed and then I'll see you
so Monday's episode everyone have a good
weekend next week Tuesday through Friday
Jackson Claude cameras by the way our
new episode of Breaking Bad our final
episode ever is on Spotify right now and
we do address what happened to the
flamingos people are still commenting
asking so we talk about it in the
episode of Breaking Bread it's actually
like major tea and it's really crazy but
um head over there if you want to hear
what happened
so Tuesday through Friday camera video
YouTube and podcast episodes Jackie and
Claudia together and then Monday's up in
the air it might be podcast only or it
might be a video that we record Sunday
night let's see where the weekend takes
us let's see where the weekend taste
tests so you guys it's been an amazing
week thank you for keeping you know
being patient with us with all of the
remote Studio Tings I feel like we've
gotten into a good place yesterday I
wanted to pull my hair out I made the
dumbest mistake when I was exporting our
video that delayed me about an hour and
I just like literally wanted to die like
I wanted to be dead buried in the ground
six feet under but you have to you have
to make those mistakes in order to know
like moving forward not to make them
it's you have to learn the hard way so
we're getting better I'm telling you
we're gonna get to a place where the
videos will be up a lot sooner but thank
you for your patience I hope you guys
have an amazing day and thank you so
much for listening to the morning
testimony Morning Show where we deliver
the fastest stories you need to know
every Monday through Friday and YouTube
so you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available's
podcast anywhere podcast can be found on
Spotify
all the places so whoever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast don't
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing weekend stay
safe head to girl with no job.com tour
um if you're not ugly and I love you bye
bye